ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BENNETT.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
CHEN CHIU. CHOI COOLEY. COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY. LEAD
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA IN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK MARK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
T. WELL THERE IS V. APPROVED
VIA. VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY FAMILY MEMBER
FLORIDA ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR.
COLLEAGUES PLAY WITH ME.
HEAVENLY FATHER ASK YOUR
BLESSING ON EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US HERE TODAY. ASK YOUR
BLESSING ON THIS GREAT STATE IN
OUR INCREDIBLE COUNTRY THAT WE
ARE SO PRIVILEGED TO LIVE IN. I
PREFER PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALING FOR ALL THOSE WHO ARE
HURTING LONELY AND LOST. GIVE
US WISDOM TO REPRESENT OUR
STATE IN THE WAY THAT PLEASES
YOU. AND IN YOUR HOLY NAME AMEN.
THANK YOU MISTER FARA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE FIGHT FROM THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. REDDING
BEGAN RIGHT TO THE FLAG YEAH OF
AMERICA AND. IMPERIAL WITH.
KALRA THANK YOU MAYBE SEE
MOVING TO READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S TURN GOLDEN ONE
CENTER WHEN IT IS SEVENTH
TWENTY. AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THE READING OF THE
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED
WITH. PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MITHRAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I REQUEST ANONYMOUS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BY OUT BY THAT IS PETRIE-NORRIS
DALY LACKEY PERKS SILVA FLORIN
RODRIGUEZ TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. THE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. THERE ARE NO ITEMS ON THE
DAILY FILE. FILE ITEM. ONE WILL
BE PASSED THE ROUTINES. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
NASTY GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR WE
ARE BEGINNING OUR TOURNAMENTS
IN MEMORY YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION IS APPRECIATED. THE
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY LOST A
HERO THIS MONTH WILLIAM L.
REYNOLDS WAS BORN ON AUGUST
FIFTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX AND
MINERAL WELLS TEXAS BELL AS WE
ALL KNEW HIM WAS A VIETNAM
VETERAN AND THE CHARLIE COMPANY
OF THE FOURTH FORTY SEVEN.
NINTH INFANTRY DIVISION HE WAS
ONE OF THE FAMOUS BOYS OF SIXTY
SEVEN CHRONICLED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE BOOK BY DR
ANDREW WEISS AND THE BASIS OF A
NATIONAL GEOGRPHIC DOCUMENTARY
BROTHERS IN WAR. BUILT WAS AN
UNWAVERING ADVOCATE FOR THE
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY'S MILITARY
VETERANS HE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO ADVOCATE FOR HIS FELLOW
MILITARY BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
HE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY VETERANS
MEMORIAL AND THE MAN BEHIND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE FALLEN
WARRIORS MONUMENT A MEMORIAL
WALL HONORING VETERANS BOTH
KNOWN AND UNKNOWN AT THE
VETERANS HISTORICAL PLAZA IN
NEW HALL. BILL SPEND TWO YEARS
SEARCHING THROUGH OUR LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS ARE TIED TO FIND
ACCOUNTS OF LOCAL RESIDENTS WHO
DIED DURING COMPLEX DEFENDING
THEIR NATION HE FOUND NEARLY
FIFTY THAT WERE MORE ALLIES ON
THE GROUND AT MONUMENT. WHITE
SIMPLY BUILD. HELPED THE
STORIES OF OUR WAR HEROES. WAR
HEROES THAT ALSO CALLED SANTA
CLARITA HOME. WELL MANY NEW
BILL FOR HIS COMMUNITY SERVICE
AND HAS WORK WITHIN THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY. I KNEW HIM AS A
FRIEND AND SOMEONE WHO WAS
ALWAYS VOCAL WHO SPOKE UP FOR
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR COUNTRY.
BILL HAD NO PROBLEM HAVING A
WAR OF WORDS WITH YOU BUT HE
ALWAYS WAS WILLING TO SIT DOWN
AND LISTEN TO YOUR VIEWPOINT.
TODAY WE HONOR HIM AS A VETERAN
WHO GAVE A PART OF HIMSELF. FOR
OUR NATION AND WE ADMIRE ALL OF
THE WORK HE HAS DONE FOR THOSE
WHO FOUGHT WITH HIM. AND BEFORE
HAND. BILL YOU WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED GODSPEED MY FRIEND.
THANK YOU A FIGHTER'S MOVES
BETWEEN OURS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF GAL MALAN. WE
RECENTLY LOST CAL TO A MULTI
YEAR BATTLE WITH CANCER AND I
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER HIM AS A
KIND DYNAMIC AND ENGAGED LEADER
IN MY LOCAL COMMUNITY. GIL IS A
PROUD U. S. ARMY VETERAN AND A
BOARD MEMBER FOR A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE MOTORCYCLE
RIGHTS AND SAFETY ORGANIZATION.
SKILLS LAB FOR MOTORCYCLES AND
ENGINES BEGAN AND YOUNG AGE
BUILDING BIKES WITH HIS FATHER
AND THE SELLER OF THEIR HOME IS
HE GREW UP. GILL'S AFFINITY FOR
ENGINES AND MACHINERY
FLOURISHED IN THE U. S. ARMY
WHERE HE WAS PART AT THE
SEVENTIETH CENTURY BATTALION.
AND SEVENTIETH ENGINEER
BATTALION. OPERATING BULLDOZERS
AND CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT AS
WELL AS QUALIFYING AS AN EXPERT
RIFLEMAN AND MARKSMAN. IN THE
CART CARBINE. AFTER HIS
MILITARY SERVICE GIL SETTLED IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE HE WORKED AS A
MARINE MECHANIC IN THE LOCAL
HARBORS I GOT HEAVILY INVOLVED
IN GRASSROOTS VETERANS AND
MOTORCYCLISTS ORGANIZATIONS.
SERVING AS A BAIT OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND BOARD MEMBER UNTIL
HIS PASSING. I FEEL LUCKY TO
HAVE MET GALA DURING MY TIME IN
OFFICE AND I AM GRATEFUL FOR
HIS SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
A SERVICE TO MY COMMUNITY. WE
EXTEND OUR DEEP CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME MAY HIS MEMORY
BE A BLESSING. THANK YOU MISTER
GENEROUS MISTER LACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. ARISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF XANDER ELLIS OLE FROM.
AGE EIGHTY FIVE OF SAN DEMUS.
LOS A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER
ON DECEMBER TWENTY SIX. HE WAS
A LIFELONG RESIDENT. IN
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVED AS A
CONVENE A FIREFIGHTER.
419-662-1990 TWO. HE WAS A
SERGEANT IN THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD SERVING FROM.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR TO NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO. AFTER HIS RETIREMENT
UNTIL HIS FINAL ILLNESS HE WAS
AN AVID GOLFER I WAS PROUD OF
HIS FOUR HOLES IN ONE. HE IS
SURVIVED AND IF YOU'RE A GOLFER
YOU REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DIXIE. THE SON GARY THE
ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY
CONSULTANT. MAYES AND REST IN
PEACE AND I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. OF SAN ELLIS ALL FROM
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CAYMUS KIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I INTRODUCED YOU
TO CHARLES LAUREN DAHLE WHO
PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH AND TWENTY TWENTY OUR
COMMUNITY LOST A FAIR MINDED
INTELLIGENT INSIGHTFUL MAN THAT
DAY AT HIS RETIREMENT IS
COLLEAGUES GAVE HIM A UNIQUE
TOKEN A FIVE FOOT LONG WALKING
STICK THEY DUBBED AS YODA STICK
IN HONOR OF HIS REPUTATION AS A
VERY WISE MAN. LAUREN WAS BORN
IN PORTLAND OREGON ON AUGUST
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO AND
HE GRADUATED FROM YOU SOUTH
EUGENE HIGH SCHOOL WAS EDUCATED
AS AN ELECTRICAL ENGINEER AT
OREGON STATE UNIVERSITY. AFTER
GRADUATION HE SERVED AS AN
ENGINEER AT THE NAVAL YARD AND
REMEMBER QUE IN WASHINGTON. HE
WENT ON TO EARN HIS PHD IN
BUSINESS FROM PURDUE
UNIVERSITY. AFTER SEVERAL YEARS
AS A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF BRITISH COLUMBIA
INITIATED A SERIES OF THREE
COMPUTER BUSINESSES BEFORE
LAUNCHING LCP TRACKER A
COMPUTER SOFTWARE COMPANY IN
ORANGE CALIFORNIA. HE WATCHED
HIS COMPANY GROW FROM THREE
EMPLOYEES TO ITS CURRENT ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES HIS INTEREST
INCLUDED HIS DEVOTION TO FAMILY
AND A PASSION FOR READING
SCIENCE FICTION AND FANTASY. HE
WAS A WINNING BRIDGE PLAYER A
FAN OF TV MYSTERY SERIES A
DEVOTED STUDENT OF PROGRESSIVE
POLITICS AND NAVAL HISTORY AND
A VERY ENTHUSIASTIC TRAVELER
WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
TRAVELLING TO THIRTY FIVE
COUNTRIES LAUREN ALSO HELP
STEER THE COURSE FOR THE MUSEUM
OF TEACHING AND LEARNING MOTAL.
SERVING FOR ELEVEN YEARS AS A
SECRETARY FOR THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS LAUREN WAS PRECEDED
IN HIS DEATH BY SEVERAL FATHER
CHARLES AND HIS MOTHER JANET AS
WELL AS THE SISTERS ANDREA BATH
IN HIS LATE WIFE. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE GRETA HIS
CHILDREN RYAN AND GERRICK AND
DAUGHTER IN LAW STACY AND
STEPCHILDREN CHRISTINA AND PAUL
AS WELL AS HIS GRANDCHILDREN
JADE AND JOSHUA AND GREAT
GRANDDAUGHTER AUBREY AND I
ASKED INTERN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS KIRK SYLVESTER
FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. IT S WITH GREAT
SADNESS I RISE TODAY TO A
GERMAN THE MEMORY OF DENNIS
COMING. PASSED AWAY IN DECEMBER
DENNIS WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX. FOLLOWING HIS HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION DENNIS JOINED
AIRFORCE WHERE HE SERVED FOUR
YEARS. HE WAS A MEMBER OF MANY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA. THE
GREATER YOU SOMEBODY COUNCIL
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
ROTARY CLUB. HE WAS A PRIVATE
PILOT ENJOYED RESTORING WORLD
WAR TWO AIRCRAFT UP UNTIL HIS
DEATH. DENNIS IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE RABRI. HIS CHILDREN
NINE GRANDCHILDREN FOURTEEN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE JOIN
ME IN DURING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR FOR A MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THE RETURN IN
MEMORY. OF AMELIA TERESA
MARTINEZ KNOWN AS TERRY. BY
THOSE CLOSE TO HER WHO PASSED
AWAY LAST WEEK DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS BROUGHT ON BY
COVERT NINETEEN. TERRY SERVED
HER COMMUNITY AS AN OFFICER FOR
THE HELL HOME BACK TO VISION
LOSS SENDS POLICE DEPARTMENT
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND
LIVED IN THE CITY OF CHINO.
FAMILY DESCRIBES HER AS TO
NATION'S WOODY AND DETERMINE
SO. AND DEDICATION AND DEVOTION
SHE HAD FOR HER WORK AND FOR
FAMILY WAS EXTRAORDINARY. JERRY
LOVED TO TRAVEL LOVE HER
DAUGHTER'S IN ANGELS DEPENDING
ON WHO IS PLAYING AND WILL
SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH THROUGH
LEGACY L. A. WHOSE MOTTO IS
WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE DREAM BIG.
SURE SURVIVED BY HER THREE
SURVIVING CHILDREN ROBERT
STEPHEN AND AMANDA AS WELL AS A
BEAUTIFUL GRANDDAUGHTER NAME
FAMILY. MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING MEMBERS OF OFFICER
TERRY MARTINEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURN IN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL LIVING TODAY'S
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY'S OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY OUR TOES
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE NOTE THE
DEADLINE IS THE MAILING REQUEST
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL IS TOMORROW
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY JANUARY TWENTY SECOND NO
FLOOR SESSION AND NO CHECK IN
SESSION. MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST. TWENTY FIFTH THERE IS-FOR SESSION AT ONE PM TODAY
THERE IS A JOINT HEARING OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR IN THE
HOUSING AND CMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- COUPON INTERNMENT
OBSESSION. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED IN
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS RACE MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH AT NINE AM.